écologie réindustrialisation emploi on
connaît donc un les priorités du plan de
relance tant attendue de l'économie
française c'est l'un des derniers à être
dévoilés en europe alors ce plan est il
à la hauteur des enjeux qu'elle dépense
véritablement nouvelle contient-il on en
parle tout de suite avec l'économiste
jacques sapir bienvenue jacques bienvenu
olivier merci alors dites-nous tour que
contient donc ce plan de relance alors
oui on a raison on a présenté ce plan
comme un plan etc c'est excessivement
ambitieux et c'est vrai qu'avec 100
milliards d'euros il y à une somme qui
en apparence est tout à fait
considérable
après il faut comprendre que ce plan est
nécessaire parce que l'économie
française est actuellement exsangue il y
a eu évidemment les deux mois de
confinement
il ya certes eu un petit rebond après le
confinement mais on voit en particulier
sur les chiffres du mois d'août sur les
chiffres d'activité du mois d'août on
voit que l'activité est en train de
retomber
et donc il faut absolument relancer
cette activité alors c'est un plan
important mais c'est un plan qui d'une
certaine manière mélange des dépenses
mais aussi tout simplement des
abattements d'impôts donc des déductions
fiscales
or ces déductions fiscales les fameuses
impôts sur la production
eh bien ce sont des ressources pour les
collectivités locales et donc il faudra
d'une certaine manière les compenser et
tout cela
d'une certaine manière ne contribue pas
à la lisibilité de la politique du
gouvernement
voyons tout cela plus en détail jacques
quels sont les grands axes de ce plan
alors ces grands axes il était en
réalité connue depuis la fin juin ou le
début juillet on peut même remonter de
ce point de vue là au projet de loi de
finances rectificative qui avait été
publiée au mois de juin il ya tout
d'abord évidemment une priorité pour la
transition énergétique vous l'avais dit
avant cette priorité elle va compter
pour à peu près 30 milliards il y a
ensuite le le volet je dirais
compétitivité et aides aux entreprises
et c'est là où on a d'une certaine
manière
lyard d'argent frais et 20 milliards de
déductions fiscales
et puis on a aussi ce fameux volet sur
la solidarité et l'emploi
un volet qui est un espèce de grand
fourre tout et qui pose d'ailleurs toute
une série de problèmes de ce point de
vue là il est clair que le premier
ministre s'est engagé d'une certaine
manière à lutter contre la montée du
chômage que l'on va connaître d'ici la
fin de l'année et il espère que ce plan
va pouvoir créer 160 mille nouveaux
emplois mais c'est très peu par rapport
à l'ensemble des emplois qui seront
détruits alors concernant le projet de
loi de finances rectificative at on
avancé sur ce point alors vous rappeler
que j'avais présenté justement ce projet
de loi de finances
dans l'émission au mois de juin oui on a
assurément avancées de ce point de vue
là alors ce projet si vous voulez il
avait à l'époque trois priorités le
tourisme l'industrie aéronautique et
l'industrie automobile qu'est ce qu'on
constate maintenant on constate tout
d'abord le fait que dans la question
énergétique et et bien il y à là toute
une série de dépenses en moins
évidemment les dépenses qui vont
importer sur la rénovation et
l'isolation thermique des bâtiments
il y a un gros secteur du transport qui
contient ce qu'on appelle le plan sncf
un plan qui en réalité avait déjà été
discuté à la fin du mois de juin et au
début du mois de juillet et qui n'est
pas nouveau de ce point de vue là bref
c'est néanmoins un plan important et
puis on a les plans sur les différentes
mobilité il ya aussi la question des
énergies vertes et quelque chose d'un
peu nouveau
une toute petite partie pour
l'agriculture après la le deuxième volet
la deuxième grande priorité c'est
évidemment reconstruire la compétitivité
de l'économie française et permettre
justement des relocalisations
alors c'est là où on voit qu'il y a un
problème puisque sur les 35 milliards y
en a 20 qui ne sont pas de l'argent
c'est en réalité des abattements
d'impôts et qui plus est des abattements
d'impôts qui sont répartis sur deux ans
pour 10 milliards en 2021 10 milliards
en 2022 ce qu'on peut constater c'est
que sur un sujet qui est un vrai sujet
si vous voulez qu'il est un sujet
important ce qui est la question des
fonds propres des entreprises
il n'y a que 3 milliards et ça c'est
très largement insuffisant et puis on a
le troisième volet est alors comme je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure il s'agit d'un
espèce de de pot pourri de différentes
mesures alors bien sûr il ya le plan des
jeunes pour l'emploi c'est justement sur
ce plan que compte
jean castex pour essayer non pas
d'inverser mais de freiner la montée du
chômage
il y a les sommes qui seront à nouveau
accordé au chômage partiel et qui ne
devrait pas figurer en réalité dans ce
plan car il ne s'agit pas de mesures de
relance il s'agit de mesures
d'accompagnement dans la crise il y a
bien entendu une petite aide pour les
collectivités locales
5 milliards mais ces 5 milliards sont
loin de compenser les 20 milliards que
les collectivités locales vont perdre
avec la suppression des impôts de
production et puis on retrouve les
grosso modo six milliards qu'ils avaient
déjà été prévues ils ont été négociés
dans le cadre du ségur de la santé donc
on le voit c'est un mélange finalement
assez hétéroclite alors long les sommes
sont elles plus importante que ce qui
avait été déjà prévu en juin alors oui
ça c'est absolument incontestable en
juin on était plutôt sûr qu'à rome 3
milliards on est là techniquement sur
100 milliards encore faut-il préciser
que les 43 milliards du mois de juin
c'était de l'argent frais et qu' on n'a
pas 100 milliards d'argent frais on a en
réalité 80 milliards si on enlève déjà
les impôts de production qui seront
supprimés et puis il ya toute une série
de plans qui ont été inclus dans ce plan
de relance des sommes qui étaient déjà
prévus par exemple on savait déjà
début juillet qu'il faudrait prolonger
le chômage partiel ça a été rajouté et
donc si on fait le total est là c'est
pas 100 milliards d'argent frais c'est
63 milliards à peu prêt d'argent frais
alors bien sûr c'est plus que les 43
milliards qui avait été prévu au mois de
juin mais on voit bien que l'on reste
quand même en deçà de ce qui est fait
par nos voisins par exemple l'allemagne
elle prévoit 130 milliards et même la
grande bretagne et l'italie prévoit en
réalité plus que nous mais il y a aussi
une spécificité dans la méthode n'est ce
pas oui et ça c'est un point qui est
d'ailleurs intéressant alors pour dire
les choses
jean castex voudrait créer ce qu'on
appelle des sous préfet justement chargé
du plan de relance l'idée et est assez
simple cela consiste à dire voilà il y
aura des gens qui sont dans les régions
ils seront dans les préfectures dans
chaque département et qui pourront
vérifier que les choses qui sont décidés
à paris sont bien appliquées dans les
départements voire pourront faire
remonter toute une série de demandes
vers paris quand les mesures en gestion
des problèmes d'application alors en
théorie c'est excellent sauf que il est
aussi précisée par lang à sète il
s'agira de jeunes hauts fonctionnaires
et ça déjà ça pose un véritable problème
des jeunes hauts fonctionnaires sont des
gens qui manquent d'expérience par
définition ce sont des gens qui seront
donc beaucoup plus sensibles on peut
même dire vulnérables tout d'abord à
l'accumulation des demandes venant des
différents acteurs mais aussi aux
pressions il faut bien comprendre que il
ya toute une série d'entreprises qui
feront un lobbying important pour
obtenir plus
et donc cela risque d'aboutir à une
forme de saupoudrage du plan et il faut
savoir le saupoudrage
c'est toujours l'un des grands périls
qui guettent les plans de l'état alors
on peut se demander effectivement
pourquoi n'at-on pas fait un guichet
unique
pourquoi n'at-on pas réinstaller ce
système qui avait fonctionné en fait
lors de la crise
de 2008 à 2010 ou pour régler l'ensemble
des problèmes et bien les entreprises
ont un seul interlocuteur et ça ça pose
un véritable problème problème dont jean
castex et probablement conscient puisque
il a insisté sur le fait que la
simplification administrative serait
justement au coeur de la réussite de ce
plan
c'est indiscutable et il faut de ce
point de vue la lui rendre
acte du fait qu'il a en tous les cas
identifié le problème
alors pour conclure jacques calais
finalement votre sentiment sur ce plan
qui vient d'être dévoilée je ne vous
cache pas que mon sentiment est assez
mitigé il est tout d'abord mitigé parce
que dans l' annonce on voit bien que ce
plan mélange des choses qui sont bonnes
des choses qui sont beaucoup plus
discutable et surtout on a le sentiment
qu'il y a une forme d' habillage
politique une forme de communication
politique dans le plan ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est un
petit malaise quand même sur les sommes
pourquoi parle-t-on de 100 milliards
alors qu'il n'ya pas 100 milliards
d'argent frais pourquoi at on voulu
ajouter dans le plan justement pour
atteindre ces fameux 100 milliards des
choses qui avaient déjà été décidées qui
était déjà prévue et qui ne devrait pas
normalement faire partie du plan donc
tout ceci crée un petit manège brouille
un petit peu l'image que voudrait donner
le gouvernement
avec ce plan fait peser un doute réel
sur l'efficacité globale de ce plan et
on sait par exemple que les déductions
d'impôts c'est pas très efficace
on l'a vérifié si vous voulez sous le
quinquennat de françois hollande avec la
fameuse affaire du crédit impôt du cic
eux mais bref je pense que il faut de ce
point de vue là attendent voir comment
les choses se mettront en place on peut
penser d'ailleurs que le gouvernement
pourrait corriger et d'ailleurs son plan
s'il voyait qu'il y avait des problèmes
au niveau
2 l'exécution et donc de ce point de vue
là laissons faire un petit peu le temps
et bien merci beaucoup jacky vous aurez
bien évidemment l'occasion de revenir
nous en parler dans les prochains mois